[Music]  how well do you know your neighbors  you see many of them every day but have  you ever wondered  what goes on behind their doors  are you associated with the deceased no  no we're neighbors in the building  so you don't know him just in passing  not his passing no yes  when we passed by before he passed  that's right  we find the right connection and all  this cracks open  i can't tell if i want it to be nothing  or to be something  we began with the question how well do  you know your neighbors  turns out the ones you thought you knew  best might be the ones you know the  least  every true crime story is actually true  for someone  and this is just occurring to you  i think we should just hit him with the  charm good excellent so i'll take the  lead on this  excuse me well i can turn on the charm  is it on now  it's just warming up  [Music]  foreign